[ __ ] la voisine a mis un mot de passe
à son réseau en appeler de wifi
maintenant à et rendons grâce au wifi
qui éclaire nos vies ça m'a vraiment
fait plaisir de les voir tes parents en
tout cas ils ont l'air en forme
oui mais sans boulot tu vois cette fille
tu vas devenir son nouveau prof
d'anglais mais j'ai zéro diplôme je
comprends pas pourquoi tu as loupé le
concours d'entrée aux beaux-arts à ferme
là s'il y avait à oxford dépôt s'est
d'ailleurs serait major de promo tu sais
papa je vois pas ce diplôme comme une
contrefaçon
il y a une opportunité à saisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais assez vite et au cou il est
ok with you
bassong lui c'est un artiste mais on a
essayé tellement de professeurs d'arts
plastiques
aucun d'eux n'a tenu en moi je connais
peut-être quelqu'un
[Musique]
tu sais le plus bizarre dans tout ça